- It's time to wash the floofy newfie.
Bear, get in here.
(upbeat music)
Newf, hi puppy.
So this is one of the
Bengal Newfoundlands.
I'm trying to be like that guy
that shows the cats on the TikTok.
Oh, he's too heavy.
Okay, you ready?
It's bath time.
You're stinky.
I took you out in the rain.
You were running around the field.
Let's go in, bath time.
Excellent job.
Bear's really easy
to wash actually, 'cause he's
just like down for anything.
But I like to tell him like I do
with my patients, all
the things I'm gonna do
before I do them.
So Bear, the first thing I'm
gonna do is turn on the water.
Then I'm gonna wet you.
I'm gonna get you very wet.
Then once that happens,
I'm gonna get the shampoo
and I'm gonna lather you up.
Once you're fully lathered,
I'm gonna make sure I get
all ends washed of you,
from top to bottom.
Do you agree?
High-five if you agree.
(paw smacking)
Okay, you agree, good.
The problem with this water is
sometimes it has really bad
control over temperature.
So I wanna make sure
that it's not too hot.
'Cause for dogs, hot water is no bueno.
The craziest thing about Bear is
that he looks huge when he's all poofy,
but when he starts getting wet,
he's actually really skinny.
Bear, how you feeling about this?
His fur is actually a
little oily, the top layer.
So it prevents water from getting in.
Bear, can I have a kiss while I wash you?
Thank you.
(Mike grunting)
So you gotta be careful when
you get dog shampoo like I did.
I got the one that's concentrated,
so you're gonna need to
dilute it pretty heavily.
Bear, this is your shampoo.
(shampoo gurgling)
All right, newfie.
(water splashing)
Oh, it's so heavy.
This is the version of a dog sponge.
So you wanna introduce it
to the dog so he feels safe
with it, lets him smell it.
I mean Bear's really laid back
so it doesn't matter at all,
what you do with him, but.
Okay, now we wash the newf,
make sure we get deep into his skin folds.
The good part about this rubbery
thing is it does a good job
of getting through the fur even the knots.
(water splashing)
Also, when you do this with your dog
it should be a fun thing.
So bringing your dog snacks is great.
Bear, do you want a snack?
Or do you wanna just lick my face?
Your breath's gonna smell better
after I brush your teeth though.
Look how much fur comes out of this guy.
(air whooshing)
Ugh!
Bear, I feel like you're concentrating
on solving a math problem.
Which math problem are you thinking about?
Clean the butt, he doesn't like that.
Good boy, Bear, good boy.
Oh my God, look at this.
(audience gasping)
I have a special
ShamWow-esque product here
where you can actually put
your hands inside of this,
and just hug your dog like
it's a giant little loofah.
Giant little loofah.
Look, it's like he's being born.
(audience gasping)
And I wanna do this as much as possible
before he starts flicking
it off all over the place.
(air whooshing)
Okay, he did it, nonetheless.
Wow, this is soaked already.
(water dripping)
Then I have the next ShamWow dog towel.
These are super absorbent
so they do a great job
at holding the water and
pulling the water off your dog.
Okay, come on.
(fur whooshing)
You see the floor is already
soaked and he just came out.
Bear, are you happy?
Yeah, who's happy?
Hang out here for a second.
Tell me this doesn't look
like the twin turbo back end of a jet.
You might look at this contraption and say
to yourself, "Why in the world
do you need such a crazy dog blower?
Dog skin is too sensitive
so you can't really use heat.
The goal with dogs in drying them,
especially big floofy dogs like Bear, is
to blow the wetness off of them.
(dryer whirring)
When you blow really forceful air,
you could actually see his skin
and that allows me as I go through,
to see if there's any rashes
or anything else popping up in his skin.
Also, a mistake that a lot of people make
with these, if you go in
like circles like this,
you could actually create
tangles in your dog's hair.
So the goal is to always
do it in one direction.
(dryer whirring)
(quirky music)
Oh, my low back!
(groans) The tail stays
wagging, right bud?
The tail's just wagging, yeah.
This is like a shearing blade, it's a comb
but on the other end, it's really sharp.
So you're going through his floof,
it could actually take extra
hair out and tangles out.
A lot of dog groomers
will avoid using these
'cause some people overuse them
and start like ripping
hair outta their dogs.
So you have to be really conscientious
about how you use this.
"Get a newfie," they say.
"It'd be fun," they say.
When hair clumps together
on a dog like this, oxygen
and air stops being
able to pass through it.
The dog becomes more vulnerable
to skin infections, fungal and bacterial.
I had a groomer for about a year
and then they just started
jacking up their prices
to like $600, even though
this takes only two hours.
I mean, they do come to you
but then their scheduling
system was a mess,
and I actually enjoy doing this.
The only negative part
about this is, obviously
the hair everywhere
so you have to vacuum after.
And then, also the fact that
my water pressure sucks,
but otherwise it's great.
It's very therapeutic.
It's probably why moms
or dads braid their children's hair.
It's like it's fun for them.
And you also see that in other primates.
I think monkeys love
grooming each other too.
I feel like I'm a monkey
right now grooming a bear.
Interspecies grooming.
Do you think he likes it, though?
Look at this guy (chuckles).
Drooling.
This is a wire brush.
It's good for finishing his coat
but I also use it in between
to sort of get some of
the smaller tangles out
before I go with the bigger brush.
Didn't he get bigger?
It's 'cause he gets floofier.
(mellow music)
(brush clicking)
Just crazy.
Again, whatever thing you use
on your dog, introduce it to the dog.
Bear hasn't seen this in a little while
'cause I wasn't clipping him so I need him
to be calm when I turn this on,
turn that on, let him see
that nothing bad happens.
And then, basically, I
just wanna clean up the fur
in between his paws here,
'cause when it overgrows
it can be a problem.
(trimmer whirring)
I'm actually surprised
Bear is so comfortable
with letting me play
with his paws because,
when he was a puppy he
actually cut his paw real bad
and I had to take staples out of it
after he got an operation and
he let me do it like a champ.
But it's important when your dog's a puppy
that you handle their paws regularly
for this exact reason, so
that you can groom your dog.
Here we have a Dremel, which
is how I shorten Bear's nails.
If you actually apply a
slight pressure to the top
of the nail and to the bottom
of the paw pad like this,
you can express the nail
a little bit further
which will allow you to
visualize the vein better.
(Dremel whirring)
Newf, it's time to take
care of your gums and teeth
to make sure that you don't get cavities.
Bear is a little annoying
when brushing his teeth,
'cause he likes to eat the toothbrush.
Okay, so we're gonna get
some of the toothpaste
on the toothbrush
and Bear will give you his teeth
and allow you to brush them.
(toothbrush grazing)
And he'll eat the toothpaste, like I said.
This is not a glamorous job,
but it's a job that someone has to do.
The hardest part is
getting the back teeth.
Yeah, I'm getting those back teeth.
Don't chew the toothbrush.
Just wait, wait before you
chew the toothbrush please.
I actually don't mind
when he chews so much
on the back ones,
'cause then it's like he's
helping me brush them.
Next, we need to clean the inside
of, well, not really the inside,
more like the outer inside of Bear's ear.
And I have these special
wipes that my vet recommended.
They're called Vet's Best.
They have witch hazel, aloe vera
and tea tree oil, all good
ingredients against infections.
The goal is not to go
inside your dog's ear fully,
but just to visualize the
ear and get the gunk out.
Bear gets a lot of gunk in his ears, again
because of his floopiness of his ears.
See how gross it is already?
I also, sometimes will use a solution
if there's like a lot of ear wax
or a lot of buildup that you actually put
into his ear and then let
him shake his ear out.
Oh, and a lot of people
don't let their dogs shake their heads
when they're cleaning their ears.
Definitely let them, 'cause
that could mean some water got in there
and the way that they
get it out is by shaking.
Last part of Bear's grooming routine is
to get him outside of the
bathroom away from all this hair.
Before we move on
to the next section, status
check-in of the Bear floof hair.
(suspenseful music)
All right, part two, we wanna
get him out of the bathroom
because it's really
wet in there and hairy.
So we wanna do the
finishing touches in here.
He's already coming to join us.
All right, newf, we're
gonna finish your coat now
and blow you out,
and then I'm gonna do a
little haircut for you
because you're getting
a little bit too poofy.
High-five if that's okay.
(paw smacking)
Okay, good.
(dryer whirring)
Play dead.
Not the most glamorous
part of owning a dog,
shaving his (beep).
But, he gets a lot of rashes here
'cause of the moisture gets trapped.
(mellow music)
(Bear's heart lub-dubbing)
Isn't this incredible, Dad?
Well, how would Bear survive in the wild?
That's my question.
He would get so matted so
quickly on his first day
of being wet, he would get
skin infections galore.
(Mike chuckling)
I think this is already more fur
than what we had in the bathroom.
Yeah, this is your favorite
part, I know, I know.
The least glamorous part
of having a dog here,
he's looking back at me as I do it.
Yeah, clean my butt.
(scissors clicking)
Gotta keep the back area
hygienic, right, newf?
Look at the shine on this coat.
This is a healthy mammal right here.
How do you feel?
(Bear barking)
You smell nice.
Mmm, who's happy?
Who's happy?
Come gimme a hug.
Yeah, you're happy, yeah.
Your breath smells nice.
All right, the floof is clean.
He's dry for the most part, he's happy.
Look at how much fur leaves this animal.
And honestly, if I sat here brushing him
for another hour, probably
I could double this.
But as you could tell, it's pretty easy
to groom a dog that behaves well.
So it's important to handle
your dog early, get them used
to you being the owner
and playing with them
and cleaning their ears and their teeth
and their paws,
because then it becomes
a rewarding experience
for the both of you.
That's why Bear's a happy pup, right?
(Bear barking)
Yeah, good boy.
Check out Bear's video
when I first got him.
Click here to check that out.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(signal beeping)
(ominous music)